a myanmar army base  burns karen rebels attacked at dawn this  week  fierce fighting followed sending bullets  flying over the border hundreds of  ties were forced from their homes da  says it's the worst fighting she's seen  in 30 years  children mothers and elderly thais are  among those who fled  some taking shelter in a local school  volunteers are preparing meals for 450  people  conflict by the border has left many  fearing for their safety  net  myanmar's army has retaliated with air  strikes  bombing rebel-held areas locals have  sought refuge  in the jungle or across the river in  thailand  in the last month refugees from myanmar  have fled across this border and now  thai residents have been forced  temporarily from their homes  the fighting in myanmar is no longer  just affecting the burmese  the longer this conflict continues the  more  widespread the damage sending shock  waves through myanmar  and now into thailand siobhan robbins  sky news on the thai myanmar border